hi guys and welcome to Med simplified
I'm Dr Umar Malik and I welcome you all
to my channel I can't believe I'm
finally here face to face with all of
you first and foremost I want to express
my deepest gratitude to each and every
one of you your love and support have
been the driving Factor behind the
success of this Channel and I want to
thank all my subscribers for watching
and sharing my videos I started this
channel back in 2014 When I Was
preparing for my pre-final medical
examinations at that time I just had a
vision of simplifying medical education
for college going students like myself I
wanted to make videos in which I broke
down complex medical topics and made
them easier to understand but little did
I know that my humble Venture would grow
into such a large and Vibrant Community
of viewers like yourselves over the
years Med simplified has evolved a lot
initially I was just making videos
related to medical education but slowly
as I progressed over over the years I
started making videos related to health
diet nutrition and treatment of some
common diseases and I got such a
positive response from all of you guys
that really motivated me to make more
videos and I was truly humbled when our
growing Community reached 1 million
subscribers in 2021 it has been such an
exciting journey and I hope you all have
found value in the diverse content that
I have been producing also many of my
subscribers have messaged me to share
more about myself well I'm Dr Umar Malik
and I belong to the beautiful country of
India I reside in the northernmost part
of India known as Jammu and Kashmir it
is a very very beautiful state and it is
very popular in India both for its
conflict with Pakistan and also for its
tourism and beautiful places I completed
my medical graduation in 2018 and then I
joined Masters in dermatology in 2019
but eventually I dropped out after two
years because I didn't find dermatology
that interesting my passion always lay
in teaching and making videos for this
channel so I continued to work for this
channel but um I have recently decided
to pursue my Master's Degree again but
this time I will be joining in a
non-clinical research Branch most
probably pharmacology and my masters is
set to start from October this year
apart from being a doctor and making
videos for this channel I love to travel
and I love photography and filmmaking
photography and filmmaking have always
been my Great Escape whenever I'm
stressed whenever I'm bored I always
pick up my cameras my drones and I go
for filming and I have made a short clip
of some good shots that I've made over
the years and I want you guys to have a
look
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
I hope you liked that video if you want
to follow my photography and see more
videos like this you can follow me on my
Instagram page named lost in the knots I
will leave a link to that page in the
description box down below today I also
wanted to share with you about the
future of this channel like I told you I
love science and I love explaining
things that's why I have decided to make
videos in which we will explore the cool
science behind various Health topics I
want to make videos that are really
informative and entertaining to watch at
the same time we will talk about various
topics related to the science that
happens inside the human body and we
will try to understand that in a very
easy manner with the help of some
amazing visuals also I want Med
simplified to be an interactive platform
where you my viewers can interact with
me I will be making a lot of q a videos
where I will be answering your questions
and queries directly your feedback will
be very important in shaping the content
that we'll be producing in the future so
I think with this I should wrap up this
video and before I do that I want to
express my deepest gratitude once again
thank you so much for being a part of
Med simplified and thank you so much for
supporting me on this incredible journey
together we will make amazing videos and
explore the fascinating world of Health
thank you so much for watching and until
next time stay healthy and stay curious
I'll see you